Good morning, Hank, it's Fri- Blue guys, what
are you doing lyin' around on the job? Show
some respect for my audience.
That's better.
So Hank, I've been sick lately - in fact,
I have a note from my doctor saying I don't
have to do my punishment - but I wanted to
continue our conversation about religion.
But I also know that some people find that
kinda boring, so here's some dancing, dancing,
dancing, dancing, dancing, dance, dance, dance,
dance!
Right, so Hank, in your video on Wednesday,
you pointed out how difficult it can be to
answer yes or no questions like "Do you believe
in God?" because you have to define terms
like "believe" and "God." Also, "in." And
that made me think about how difficult it
is to define any religious identity.
Like, for instance, Muslims - Muslims believe
in the Five Pillars of Islam, right? You have
the shahada, the belief that there is no God
but God; prayer, at least five times a day.
Then you have almsgiving or zakat, the pilgrimage
to Mecca, and there's a fifth one - Ramadan.
Right, so those are the Five Pillars of Islam,
the foundation of Islamic belief. Except the
majority of Muslims don't follow the Five
Pillars of Islam; for instance, the majority
of Muslims don't pray five times a day.
Similarly, many Jews don't practice kosher,
many Buddhists disagree radically about the
nature of Nirvana and the path to get there,
and many Christians think other Christians
are going to hell because they believe that
Jesus visited America or because they believe
in transubstantiation, or all kinds of things.
In fact Hank, one time when I was in college,
I visited a Pentecostal church in rural Florida,
and it was really interesting. There was this
one moment when a woman said to the pastor,
"Could you pray for my sister? She's on this
horrible path to damnation. She's completely
lost." And the pastor was like, "Yeah, what's
the problem?" And the woman was like, "She's
going to the Pentecostal church across the
street." And then the pastor was like, "Oh
yeah, that is a problem."
So even if you open up all the matryoshka
dolls, even within a particular denomination
of a particular sect of a particular religious
tradition, there are still big disagreements.
I mean, one of the fascinating things about
identifying yourself within a religious tradition
is that, no matter who you are, there will
always be people within that very religious
tradition who say that you are not Jewish
or Muslim or Christian or whatever.
Okay, this is getting a little serious. Let's
dance. Dance, dance, dancin', dance, dance
dance dance, dance, dance!
This makes it incredibly challenging to define
the word "Christian" or "Muslim" or "Jew,"
because ultimately, there are Muslims who
I have more theologically in common with than
many of my fellow Christians. And I think
that's one of the reasons religious traditions
often look back to some point in history where
it seems like things weren't as fuzzy as they
are now. Like in Islam there's the Age of
the Golden Caliphate - the first four caliphs;
in Christianity there's, you know, Paul and
the initial apostles when Christianity was
first starting to grow; in Judaism you have
the rule of King David. But the truth is that
there was never a golden age, and certainly
there's no way to recapture the golden age
by trying to go back to it. We know this,
Hank, due to thousands of years of failure.
So how do you know, for instance, if you're
a nerdfighter? You as a nerdfighter are constantly
inventing and evolving the definition of that
word. So please don't forget to be awesome.
Hank, I will see you on Monday.